okay today I'm going to talk to you
about drug development now in order to
get new drugs onto the market in order
to treat people who are unwell there
needs to be lots of tests that happen to
make sure that it's safe for people
taking that drug so what we're going to
look at today is we're going to look at
the different stages involved what's the
point of each of those stages and also a
little bit about blind and double-blind
trials as well so to begin with in drug
development there's kind of two
completely different sections one is
preclinical testing and one is clinical
testing so preclinical testing just
means before they're in pit before the
drug is tested with people and clinical
testing involves testing drugs on people
so the very first stage of drug
development is testing it in cells so
tissue culture in labs so what you do is
you get drugs and you put them onto
different cells so you could get some
human cells here and you see other cell
other cells damaged by the drug the
cells responding how they should do when
this drug is added so at the moment no
one has been harmed so on to the second
step if the first step they've seen
positive results in working themselves
and tissue culture then the second step
you test the drugs on animals now a lot
of people disagree with these this stage
they think it's unfair because the
animals can't give consent I can't say
it's okay but the drugs are tested on
animals again the whole point of testing
the drug on animals is to see if the
drug is toxic and to what extent is it
toxic and to get an idea of dosage so
that's preclinical testing because we
haven't tested on any people yet the
next test is to test it number three on
healthy people or healthy volunteer
even so people volunteer to have the
drug tested on them so the reason why we
test on healthy people rather than
people who are ill its first of all if
they if they were ill they might they
might be weakened and if there's any bad
side effects it might kill them or
really hurt them secondly if the
person's ill it would be difficult to
tell if the side effects are caused by
the drug or by their illness so the
point of testing and healthy volunteers
is in order to find any side effects and
also to find the optimum dosage the dose
of the level of that drug where it works
the best
now once you've tested it on healthy
volunteers our next step is then to test
it on ill volunteers so now we see if
the drug actually works how it's
supposed to so here's someone ill in bed
no thermometer right so we then tested
in ill volunteers in order to see if it
actually works
does it actually do what it's set out to
do
does it help this person who's ill with
a certain disease and the final one once
all of that stuff has gone through
remember this is clinical testing
because it's with people once this is
all gone through the final thing that
needs to happen is it needs to be
approved by a medical agency so that
just means someone reviews or rather an
agency reviews all of this information
that they've collected about the drug at
every single step and they say right is
it safe to sell to the general public
and only once it's been approved then we
can sell to the general public however
we need to know a little bit more about
this stage here about clinical trials
how do they work so clinical testing is
kind of works a bit like this so you
have a doctor so here's our doctor right
here and what they do is they have they
have two different groups
so you've got two different volunteers
because basically the idea is you want
to see if this drug works so you're
going to give the drug to one person and
the o'the said one person is going to be
given the drug the other person is in a
control group so the point of control
group is to see if there's any
difference between the drug group and
the control group to make sure the drugs
doing something however we can't just
give the drug to to the drug group and
nothing to the control group because of
this thing called the placebo effect now
what the placebo effect is this person
might just think they're getting better
because they've taken something it's
like a psychosomatic effect so what we
do is we give this person in this
control group a placebo so we give them
a pill that's just like this drug it
kind of tastes the same it's sugary the
same size everything like that but only
it doesn't have the active ingredient in
so placebo it's like a dummy drug now
what we've got to do is you've got to
make sure that that the the two people
don't know which one is in is taking the
drug and which one's taking the placebo
this is called a blind trial so the
patients don't know whether they're in
the drug group or they're in the control
group now that's kind of one way we
actually go a step further because the
doctor if they know which group is which
they might be influenced subconsciously
on their results as well so what we
actually have is something called a
double-blind trial now what this is is
neither the patient or the doctor know
which group is the drug group and which
group is the perceiver group
so just to summarize just the summarize
before the different states involved its
preclinical it's before it gets the
people they test it in a lab on cells
and tissue culture they then if it's
safe test it on animals or if it's
successful they taste it on animals to
find the dose dosage of the toxicity
then they grieve runs of clinical trials
clinical trials remember they can either
be well ideally they're a double-blind
trial where neither that the person
taking the drug no the control group
knows which ones which if it's
successful they test it on ill
volunteers to see if it works and
finally gets improved by medical agency
and we could sell it in order to try and
help people around the world thank you